[Musique]
si l'on en croit les grandes
déclarations de nicolas sarkozy c'est un
peu comme si mitterrand avait laissé
tomber l'abolition de la peine de mort
ou obama sa couverture santé dans notre
président semblait avoir pris à coeur
les engagements signés en 2007 avec le
pacte écologique
le premier c'est faire un grand
ministère de l'environnement numéro deux
du gouvernement c'est fait le deuxième
c'était la création de la taxe carbone
je ne comprends pas comment comment
comment on peut avoir signé le pacte de
nicolas hulot
au printemps 2007
et aujourd'hui renier sa parole et ne
pas faire ce qu'on a dit on aurait gelé
signé je le fais c'est une question
d'honnêteté et pourtant six mois plus
tard c'est l'abandon en rase campagne
dommage collatéral des régionales la
taxe carbone est reporté à une
hypothétique décision européenne au
désespoir de chantal jouanno et de
michel rocard président de la commission
chargée de sa création tout de même pas
laisser la planète devenir doucement une
poêle à frire dans laquelle la vie
deviendra impossible d' accords scellant
c'est pour dans dix ou douze générations
mais d'orange et une dizaine d'années
pour les gens qui prendront du retard
dans le combat contre eux on parle à m
contre l'humanité seulement voilà après
l'échec du sommet de copenhague et le
rejet de la taxe carbone par le conseil
constitutionnel en décembre dernier
l'écologie présidentielle a pris du
plomb dans l aile je voudrais d'ailleurs
au point où j'en suis dire un mot de
toutes ces questions d'environnement
parce que là aussi ça commence à bien
faire une petite phrase pour les
agriculteurs qui en dit long sur la
tambouille électorale dénoncée par
nicolas hulot c'est contradictoire c'est
qu'on a un mouvement écologiste qui
s'est développée depuis des années et
qui là arrive à des niveaux qui
n'avaient pas auparavant et en même
temps neuf depuis 2007 une majorité de
droite en place qui fait une ouverture à
l'écologie ce qu est une surprise on s'y
attendait pas du tout donc la question
est ce que ça veut dire que le fait de
faire cette ouverture à l'écologie va
rapporter des voix à l'ump la majorité
de droite a fait curieusement non on a
vu ça m'a donné les élections les
électeurs écologistes ils ont voté pour
europe écologie toi qui as pas de gains
politiques considérables de ça
d'ailleurs en ces temps et d'écolo
scepticisme on ne peut pas dire qu'il y
ait grand monde pour regretter cette
taxe à laquelle personne ne semble avoir
rien compris les 200 euros qu'on vous
donne ça peut être plus que nous n'avait
dépensé parce qu'en fait en en ayant
justement réussi à faire des économies
d'énergie
eh bien vous y arriverez je suis amusé
un gaz carbonique là
le problème c'est que l' usine à gaz
carbonique aujourd'hui c'est notre
planète et que ce manque de pédagogie
risque de nous coûter très cher tous les
économistes qui se sont au niveau
mondial qui se penche sur cette question
conclut la même à la même chose qui est
que le les gaz à effet de serre n'ayant
pas de prix n'ayant pas de coût pour
ceux qui les émettent il n'y a aucune
raison de réduire leurs émissions de gaz
à effet de serre donc il va bien falloir
que dans le système économique
les pollueurs paye quelque chose
fonction de leur position la fiscalité
verte étant l'ex majeur de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique que
restera-t-il du grenelle de
l'environnement après son abandon
réponse en mai lors du vote de la loi
grenelle 2
noël mamère benoît hartmann bonsoir
ongles devant un reportage de céline
jolie partir de la polémique entoure et
l'abandon par le gouvernement de la taxe
carbone qui est une mesure emblématique
on va dire du grenelle de
l'environnement et qui avait été
présenté par notre président comme un
élément essentiel de la révolution verte
et même du new deal économique alors on
se demande après de telles ambitions et
une façon d'en rabattre s'il ne faudrait
pas enterrer le grenelle de
l'environnement alors j'ai souhaité en
parler avec vous alors vous noël mamère
député verts maire de bègles vous avez
été journaliste pendant une trentaine
d'années vous êtes nouvellement avocat
vous êtes avocat depuis quelques temps
l'ancien avocat qui a procédé à trois
puis doit rimer des priorités et vol
pour le prolongement de mes combats
politiques alors vous avez aussi
souhaité à la suite de l'abandon de
cette taxe carbone qui est
l'organisation d'un grenelle alternatif
alors quand on entend une proposition
comme ça est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il
est déjà enterré le grenelle de
l'environnement juste heureux et je
pense que le grenelle de l'environnement
c'est devenu une sorte d'astre mort car
il a été complètement siphonnés de
l'essentiel de ce qu'avait proposé ce
qui était venu avec beaucoup de
sincérité autour de la table la taxe
carbone c'est ce qui a effectivement de
plus emblématiques dans cette espèce de
et pouye âge littérale du grenelle de
l'environnement donc nous allons être
appelés à nous prononcer sur le grenelle
2 c'est là la deuxième mois qui concerne
le donneur donc mise en oeuvre du
grenelle à partir du à partir du mois de
mai le grenelle 2 cc si la partie c'est
le dur c'est là où on voit tout et où on
voit que les grands de votre l'argent
qui va sera nécessaire un certain nombre
d'initiatives et je crains qu
effectivement nous soyons appelés à
voter sur un astre mort d'accord vous
benoît ramade vous êtes membre de france
nature environnement qui la fédération
des associations de protection de la
nature créée en
1968 vous avez votre badge avec vous
comme tout bon militant es vous êtes
chargé du suivi du grenelle de
l'environnement là est-ce que vous avez
est au chômage bientôt est-ce qu'il faut
enterrer ce grenelle de l'environnement
je crois vous n'êtes pas du même avis
que noël mamère nom n'est pas du même
avis l'on considère que le grenelle a
pris un coup dur un la table car wayne
l'abandon de la taxe carbone c'est un
coup dur mais pour vous donner une idée
moi je considère que c'est les morts
qu'on enterre et que là on a un moribond
un moribond ça soigne et nous on a
l'habitude que quand on nous met dehors
par la porte on revient par la fenêtre
on renonce pas à la une
à une fiscalité environnementale qui
prenne en compte tous les impacts et
c'est pas parce que ce coup là on a
perdu une bataille que la guerre est
perdue d'accord on va voir un peu
comment on va aborder le débat d'abord
revenir sur la taxe carbone pourquoi est
ce que c'est si important pourquoi on a
le sentiment qu'en abandonnant la taxe
carbone c'est l'essentiel du dispositif
du grenelle environnement qui a été
abandonnée d'abord je préfère qu'on
parle de contribution climat énergie ça
repose sur le principe de dire je vais
taxer les pollueurs et cet argent je
vais l'utiliser à faire de la
redistribution sociale entre autres et
je vais par exemple lutter contre la
précarité énergétique je vais utiliser
une partie de l'argent des pollueurs
pour indemniser les polluer en quelque
sorte c'est aussi un outil de
redistribution c'est pas seulement un
outil de lutte contre les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais c'est aussi un
outil de redistribution sociale juste un
point à point dans après les capillaires
est ce que vous croyez pas que cette
contribution climat énergie a perdu la
bataille des moûts la bataille
sémantique quand elle est venue la taxe
carbone c'est possible mais c'est pas
une taxe oui justement une taxe ça
revient dans les caisses de l'état or
même le même la taxe tech telles
qu'elles étaient proposées par le
président de la république était un
système fiscal qui n'allait pas dans les
caisses de l'état qui a été redistribué
entièrement à ceux qui sont dépendants
d'un certain nombre d'aidés des énergies
fossiles le pro le principe de la
contribution climat énergie c'est pas
une nouveauté ça existe depuis 1993 en
suède mais il la suède n'est pas le seul
pays à appliquer ce qu'on appelle la
taxe carbone qu'il faut appeler la
contribution climat énergie l'allemagne
le danemark et la finlande et la suisse
aussi juste dire également pour bien
montrer l'importance de cette
contribution climat énergie c'est que
dans l'esprit je veux dire de nicolas
hulot quand c'est dans sa proposition
elle devait être progressive oui pour
réaliser une sorte de pédagogie une
transition
elle doit être progressif pour inciter
les pollueurs à s'équiper de dans leurs
oeufs dans leur production industrielle
d'outils qui vont moins polluer donc par
exemple en suède ça a commencé je crois
à 32 euros en est à 100 maintenant et
quand les industriels et les deux îles
et les habitants savent qu'il y à une
progressivité il s'organise en fonction
de la progressivité de cet impôt alors
je vous poser une autre question est ce
que la taxe carbone ne pousse pas à la
délocalisation je m'explique à savoir
que par exemple aux états unis ou en
france on consomme des produits qui sont
fabriqués peu plus en plus à l'étranger
et notre consommation carbone notre
empreinte carbone est faible alors que
ont fait fabriquer à l'extérieur est ce
que ça c'est pas un danger la mer oui
bien sûr ça ça fait partie des ça fait
partie des de ce que l'on appelle les
clauses environnementales et les clauses
sociales que l'on nous introduire dans
les marchés donc ça ça devrait être le
rôle de l'om sait sauf que
l'organisation mondiale du commerce qui
est censé être un tribunal règle le
marché par le marché n'introduit pas des
règles d'éthique et de droit donc il ya
toute la bagarre qu'il faut mener avec
l'organisation internationale du travail
sur la condition de ceux qui travaillent
dans ces pays et qui fabrique des
produits que nous consommons et que nous
consommons de manière assez obsessionnel
il ya la question effectivement de la
clause environnementale
et puis il y à la question de notre mode
de vie dont un mode de consommation
qu'il faut faire évoluer bien évidemment
ya pas que le carbone il n'y a pas
quelqu'un dans le commerce international
on évoquait ça on peut très bien
envisager une modulation de la taxe
carbone par exemple en fonction des
filières je m'explique j'ai une filière
équitable ou bio qui vient du même pays
et j'ai une filière qui est plutôt un
pack très clean je pourrais décider aux
frontières de faire un système de
régulation qui va inciter aux
comportements vertueux qui va favoriser
certaines filières pour lequel je vais
considérer que mon bénéfice social et
mon bénéfice en terme humain est
supérieur au coût carbone série siens
parce que c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe et c'est même l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles dans une raison pour
laquelle la taxe carbone a été retoquée
c'est le nom exempt sion c'est à dire
aussi bien pour les transports aussi
bien pour l'agriculture bien sûr vous
parlez de latex sarkozysme est d'accord
mais justement mais c'est quand même de
lacombe et on est parti du grenelle
demande attendait la taxe sarkozy n
existe plus le conseil constitutionnel a
censuré la censure et vos la raison très
simple qui sont quand même normal de la
part d'un conseil constitutionnel c'est
qu'effectivement il y avait une
inégalité devant un propos donc ne
serait ce que pour ça c'était normal que
cette taxe soit censuré mais c'est pas
parce que la taxe est censuré qu'on
décide comme ça de la rayer d'un trait
mais c'est pour ça qu'on ne rit plus
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là-bas et oatei un
parlement pour ça on est des
représentants du peuple il ya des
associations on peut travailler ensemble
à essayer de trouver une formule de
contribution climat énergie qui va
permettre d'être socialement jeunesse de
l'anc et la fisker karma mais clairement
la fiscalité environnementale
pour nous de toute façon elle va arriver
donc est-ce qu'on va attendre de se la
prendre en plein dans les dents et ça
sera douloureux où est ce qu'on va être
un petit peu en avance et qu'on va
garder encore les mains mais mal à me
mettre d'accord est-ce que ça serait
dans le cadre du grenelle de
l'environnement ce que vous proposez aux
ors du grand pourquoi pas si le grenelle
de l'environnement a encore un sens il
n'ya pas que le grenelle de
l'environnement dans les outils
démocratiques qui sont à notre
disposition dans notre pays qui est
encore une démocratie il y a un
parlement avec des représentants du
peuple il ya des choses qu'on ne dispute
pas la marque par exemple dans ce
parlement parle pas du nucléaire on n'a
jamais débattu du nucléaire le nucléaire
d'ailleurs faut quand même le dire à
ceux qui ne les écoute il a été exclu du
grenelle de l'environnement donc venir
nous raconter aujourd'hui que le
nucléaire ne produit pas d'effet de
serre alors qu'on nous traite pas du
tout la question des déchets et du coût
du traitement des déchets du
démantèlement des centrales c'est une
manière de mensonges d'état dont il faut
aussi dire les choses clairement oui
c'est vrai que ce parlement il est un
peu oubliée mais la vertu du grenelle de
l'environnement c'était précisément de
mettre des gens autour de la table mais
ces gens qui sont autour de la table il
faut encore des copains comme france
nature environnement qui croit encore
mais ils croient qu'ils vont pouvoir
remettre le
bon lentement sur ses pieds ouais je
travaille je crois non ils sont pas
naïfs ils sont ils sont dans leur rôle
parce qu'il croit c'est très sincèrement
que on peut encore tirer quelque chose
de segré bon non la fondation nicolas
hulot mais sans alors si c'est déjà fait
avec nicolas côté nicolas hulot il fait
signer le pacte écologique aux candidats
à la présidentielle un candidat bleus
signent ils le il est l'initiateur il
faut le dire de la contribution climat
énergie il est l'initiateur du grenelle
de l'environnement on voit que ce
grenelle de l'environnement est bafouée
mois après mois et que l'écologie et
l'environnement qui devrait être au
coeur des politiques publiques sont
aujourd'hui devenus une variable
d'ajustement des difficultés politiques
d'une majorité nicolas hulot il a et il
est comme tout le monde il n'a pas envie
d'être humilié en permanence donc idiot
on a l'impression que la position c'est
un petit peu dur nuancé à souk assouplir
s'est légèrement assouplis
clairement nous l'impression qu'on a eu
plutôt un complément mais bien sûr qu'on
comprend enfin il est c'est identitaire
pour la fmh la fondation nicolas hulot
elle s'est constituée autour de cette
idée autour du pacte écologique nous
forcément on comprend et on partage et
c'est douloureux mais pour autant le
grenelle de l'environnement on peut pas
le résumer à une taxe carbone fin il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses et
honnête une tout son sens de la mesure
voilà et on considère pas pour nous en
agriculture en transport faire plein de
questions évoquées et on considère pas
pour nous d'abord c'est l'alpha et
l'oméga de de l'environnement parce
qu'on va pas résoudre tous les problèmes
avec deux grenelle très clairement en
revanche c'est un minimum donc il va
falloir passer par cette étape là pour
ensuite passer à quelque chose de plus
ambitieux mais on considère qu'il faut
d'abord pointé ma mère moi je me posais
des questions de moi je suis dans
l'échangé en tant que syndic nature
environnement jantes escaliers moment
note hartmann mais moi j'y crois plus
aux jeunes à l'environnement c'est clair
ils s'éclairent tort du medef c'est une
victoire de ceux qui ne voulaient pas
des lobbies de cette wii 2 grands lobbys
oui et d'ailleurs regardez premier geste
politique après les élections régionales
le président de la république rend
visite acquis aux céréaliers les
céréaliers ce sont ceux qui aujourd'hui
sans les principaux ennemis de
l'agriculture paysanne qui bénéficie le
plus des subventions européennes
et c'est à cela qu'il est allé rendre
visite c'est un geste très politique
mais vous avez encore attendre et elle
m'a verger vous arrêtez vie oui est ce
que vous voulez dire que tout ce
grenelle l'environnement n'était qu'une
manoeuvre politique pour capter
l'électorat vert je pense que satisfait
la villa ça c'est clair que pour le
président de la république
le grenelle de l'environnement et quand
ils ont juré la main sur le coeur qu'il
allait sauver les montagnes les forêts
les paysans et que la taxe carbone
c'était une révolution aussi importante
que l'abolition de la peine de mort ou
la fin de la colonisation quand même pas
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
ils finissent par s'en apercevoir
le président de la république il s'est
aperçu que les que les électeurs de
écologistes préférer l'original à la
contrefaçon et il en a tiré une
conclusion rapide plutôt que de regarder
ce qui se fait aux états unis plutôt que
regarder ce tissu en allemagne plutôt
que regarder ce au nom de la direction
c'est de rendre indépendant écologistes
à l'orgue à la rigueur qui n'est fait
qu'il ait fait un grenelle pour des
mauvaises raisons je peux l'entendre
mais moi peu m'importe que vous avancez
dans le creuset en chantant ce qui leur
importe c'est à dire que nous à la
rigueur ce qu'il fallait saisir
l'occasion comme sont mis autour de la
table donc nous on considère que le
grenelle vous les plus agités est ce
qu'on va en faire et on considère que
c'est un processus itératif me vois pas
arrêter c'est à dire que c'est pas après
le vote de la loi au ciné qu'on va
s'arrêter parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
choses sur lesquelles on va gagner et
heureusement parce qu'on se bat et on se
bat fort pour gagner sur des
problématiques
agricole on le sait y manque des
personnes arrêtées à ce mentaliser
surtout parce que je mens on est dur à
instrumentaliser on et 3000 associations
de terrain on est vraiment dur à
instrumentaliser je vous assure qu'on a
une base qui est tonique et qui nous
rappelle à nos objectifs de façon très
régulière mais honnêtement nous on
comptait dire que c'est pas fini parce
que tant qu'on est dedans c'est pas fini
et si on quitte à ne rien y arriver noël
mamère du groupe a bien voyagé tatami
je respecte beaucoup et j'admire
l'engagement la détermination et
l'engagement de benoît et deux de ses
amis je crains que malheureusement
france nature environnement benoît et
ses copains gagne sur la périphérie et
non pas sur le coeur du grenelle de
l'environnement qui a déjà été vidé
expliqua à noël mamère comment vous
allez y arriver parce qu'il est un peu
pessimiste nous clairement jusqu'à
nouvel ordre c'est plutôt nous toujours
qui allons essayer d'y arriver sur scène
pour pour les ong nous on n'attend pas
des autres qui fasse le grenelle alors à
notre place parce que nous on est déjà
pris de la tonte pèlerins et on est déjà
dans les territoires en train de dire
vous savez ce que c'est la cheville l'a
achevé à haute valeur environnementale
c'est essayer d'évaluer la performance
environnementale d'une exploitation en
fonction du nom d'un train tous les
intrants ça veut dire que le pétrole ça
veut dire les pesticides ça veut dire
tout ça c'est une autre approche et une
approche nouvelle et nous on a pris
notre bâton de pèlerin pour aller
expliquer pour à l'expliquer à des
agriculteurs que c'est leur intérêt
c'est leur intérêt sur financier et que
c'est l'intérêt de la terre qu'ils vont
transmettre et donc on est dans une
logique où on est extrêmement proactif
et nous on accompagne partout nos
associations pour qu'elles soient partie
prenante du
mamerow n'a pas semblé très on va vous
regarder cette énergie qu'elle me fait
plaisir que nous fait du bien vous avez
cette belle énergie aussi vous y croyez
aussi parce que or on a le sentiment que
d'un côté il y aurait association qui
croient encore à travers ce grenelle
environnement et l'autre côté nous en
croire le monde notre notre l'hiver ne
se limite pas au périmètre des grenelle
de l'environnement d'accord d'autres
pensent que on c'est quoi l'avenir la
plus grande elle de l'environnement
c'est quoi la vie reprend vous c'est
qu'on aime et environnement il aura
peut-être été une étape qui aura
contribué
indéniablement à faire prendre
conscience à l'opinion publique de
l'urgence de l'urgence écologique
six ans déjà on a gagné ça c'est
important et puis je pense que de toute
façon vous voyez le
suffit de regarder le le paysage
politique de notre pays de voir quel est
aujourd'hui le poids des écologistes ou
et la tente qu'il y a de la part de la
société pour se dire qu aucun parti
politique ne peut ignorer cette attente
qu'est ce que vous espérez là pour
l'avenir proche après se voient la
lumière médias c'est un grenelle 2 qui
soit le plus ambitieux possible
honnêtement le départ de nicolas hulot
joue dans ce rapport de force et jouent
plutôt à notre faveur c'est à dire que
on est d'autant plus écouté que on est
bien à un cas quitter le bateau en
partie donc ça c'est déjà ça doit être
assez pour l'avenir immédiat mais le
grenelle pour nous c'est l'avenir c'est
pas là c'est on va pas résoudre tous les
problèmes d'environnement de la france
ont un coût dont faut pas le chauffer la
poubelle non il faudra qu en tout cas
cette discussion cette manière de
gouvernance cette manière de comment
dire de de dialogue environnemental
continue et il faudra parce que de toute
façon on peut plus en faire l'économie
encore une fois on part du principe que
si on le fait pas de façon proactive ça
va nous tomber sur le coin de la figure
il sera trop tard mais le rapport stern
le rapport stern démissionne j'ai rien
ça va nous coûter des millions de
millions d'euros donc autant autant
autant pratiquer une politique de
prévention mais moi je doute de la
sincérité de ce gouvernement je respecte
l'enthousiaste
ou pas du tout
je crains fort que quand on met pas en
cause le bouclier fiscal quand on ne
remet pas en cause la fiscalité dans
notre pays et qu'on ne donne pas sa
place à la fiscalité écologique c'est
difficile de mettre en place une
politique je dirais messieurs pour
reprendre l'expression québécoise on
lâche pas la patate ça on lâche pas la
bataille tout à la fois de vous offrir à
chacun une bande dessinée poisson pilote
qui fête ses 10 ans vous avez les fables
de la poubelle je me permets de vous les
offrir et pour vous noël mamère back in
town ce sont des gens qui ont vécu à la
campagne qui trouve que la ville quand
même il serait bon d'y retourner ces
barreaux et ubs voit la chimie à la
ville absolument messieurs en tout cas
merci et bonne lecture
[Musique]